the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think about all this stuff about I mean
your New York Times had articles about
it there's Air Force test pilots have
come out talking about encountering
flying saucers
what do you or unidentified flying
objects particularly commander flavor
whoo right had that David for everything
yeah yeah what do you think about all
that yeah we do you know I'm a shameless
marketer we do an episode on on that on
a tip on the advanced aviation threat
identification program and look again I
yeah I always say the same thing I'm not
a conspiracy guy I tend to I tend to be
very cynical about everything but after
talking to some of these folks including
forever and and a handful of others who
were both pilots and also were involved
in the a tip program for the US
government for the military there's
there's things out there that we haven't
been able to identify and I'm not
jumping on on the I'm not jumping on the
alien train necessary but what I'm
saying is that there are things that
that extremely experienced pilots
military pilots with significant amounts
of experience couldn't figure out
couldn't identify right and so I'm
certainly not gonna be smart enough to
say okay this is what it was was it a
foreign governments experimental
aircraft was it something I don't know
but what I do know is that the US
government took it seriously enough that
they developed their own internal
program within the Pentagon to try to
sort out the wheat from the chaff right
and say okay what do we actually have to
worry about in part because it's a
national security issue right if there
is a aircraft or if there's something up
there that a pilot a military pilot sees
for instance that can't identify alright
we have an obligation to figure out what
that is because if it's a hostile
foreign government's efforts and develop
you know craft that we don't know about
how to or propulsion systems we don't
know about then yes we should be working
on that issue the problem has always
been that once you talk about that then
people to me to go out aliens huh area
51 you know and it kind of gets
dismissed but there was a
much more serious effort than I I knew
about before I started working on this
thing and so I don't know I think you
know I've got an open mind about that
you know it's it's like that old you
know thing about how you know how can we
really be the only people out here and
or or
life-forms out here I don't know that
seems you know seems a little obscure
for me to believe it seems unrealistic
yeah yeah so but but I like braver yeah
that's that's the thing when someone
who's that rock-solid rhymes out and
tells the story and he's not deviating
from the story he's not a guy was trying
to make money he's just he doesn't have
a history of telling fantastic stories
and he knew what it meant when he
couldn't he didn't come forward and talk
about this and you've got the gun
cameras and you've got the radar
operators who also saw the same thing
they saw it and they said it was
actively jamming their radar yeah which
they say what the [ __ ] and then that the
way it moved from 60,000 feet down to
like 200 feet and like less than a
second and no signs of no there's no
signs of any propulsion system yeah no
there was this there's several things
about that that ya leave you scratching
your head again I'm not I'm not making a
case one way or the other you know that
the point of this is to again is to kind
of use the money trail as a way to get
inside some of these programs and then
to the degree that you can without you
know two degree that you can talk about
things that are Declassified you know
not necessarily try to make a case we're
not trying to say it is this or it is
that you know but I think we're
presenting a lot of interesting
information that you know again with
this situation with flavor as an example
you know you come away from it you think
okay I'm not dismissing anything at this
point
mmm just it's you know it be it would be
I think foolish to or anyway so
interesting stuff but was that ever
anything that came up during your career
no no we now I was pretty much
straightforward you know pound the
ground through some counterinsurgency
operations counter-narcotics
counterterrorism operations we never did
any counter alien things so that must
have been it that was a different
operation that was a that was on the
floor we weren't allowed to go on to its
headquarters seems like if we had to
admit it was real if it was something
that was real and we were being
contacted on a regular basis or at least
semi-regular basis that would change the
way everybody feels about everything yes
remember when Reagan that speech maybe
give it I think was the United Nations
you said to imagine how easily we would
come together if we were faced with a
threat from an alien world right and
everybody's like oh my god he knows
something aliens he's about to spill the
beans yeah well but think about it me
think if you know if if that did come
out which is what part of the Alaura
right is the idea that you know the
government's been keeping this from us
for all these years and and you know you
think about what that would mean not
just obviously but oh my god really
there's something going on out there but
then sort of that breakdown in trust not
that it's not happening already in terms
of the government and its ability to you
know play square but yeah I mean look
area 51 area 51 was was scouted out for
use as an experimental you know test
site for aircraft and you know made
perfect sense well then you get all
these experimental aircraft being
developed out there and flown some
successfully some not and you know
locals you know see this [ __ ] you know
locals being a fairly good-sized region
because of the the the distance on these
and you know it's understandable how you
start getting some of these stories but
you know having having said that you
know I sat down with favorite right and
we talked about this a lot for this one
episode and I talked to several others
and yeah again I come away and I'm not
sure what to think but again I'm not
closing the book on anything at this
point see the way I'd looked at it is if
these were unique expeditions from
another planet like or whatever it is
that comes here some alien spacecraft
all they'd have to do is come here once
or twice get fed up well not an ad but I
used to have a bit about how earth is
the Tijuana of outer space they only
come down here when they're [ __ ] up
and they want to see a show they don't
stay they just come down there what they
bought it like no one's doing these
science expeditions to Tijuana I'm not
going back there no way not unless I'm
drunk again yeah I was thinking that if
we're gonna come down here and examine
us I mean they could just do it a couple
of times and people have these stories
and everybody else dismisses it like
where are they worthy I don't see any
aliens yeah because you really wouldn't
and you probably do if they're capable
of moving at the speed that flavor
described where it was just impossible
to track with the human eye like they're
not gonna view us as a threat no yeah
they're not gonna think we're just I
don't know then I can look at us and say
we want to steal their technology it's
the most fascinating thing to me at all
the weird what-ifs and who could do this
and how could that be true the alien one
is the most fascinating because if that
was real and if we somehow or another
one day get some undeniable proof like
the favor filmed the film footage to
gunner footage the the the radar footage
that's pretty goddamn compelling but man
if there was something like it off the
charts
[Applause]